- And now performing
"When Love Ain't Love"
from his new album "Love Ain't Pretty,"
give it up for Charles Esten.
(audience cheering)
(playing "When Love Ain't Love")
♪ It is hard to know just how it happens ♪
♪ You start out fine ♪
♪ You're both laughing ♪
♪ But somehow somewhere
something changes ♪
♪ You find you're sitting
there like strangers ♪
♪ I've been the stayer ♪
♪ I've been the leaver ♪
♪ The guilty betrayer ♪
♪ The broken believer ♪
♪ I've walked out and
I've walked the floor ♪
♪ Been on both sides of that door ♪
♪ When love ain't love no more ♪
♪ Somebody's sorry, somebody's crying ♪
♪ 'Cause somebody found
out somebody's lying ♪
♪ Somebody says, "Please,"
somebody says, "No" ♪
♪ Somebody hangs on, somebody lets go ♪
♪ I've been the stayer ♪
♪ I've been the leaver ♪
♪ The guilty betrayer ♪
♪ The broken believer ♪
♪ I've walked out and
I've walked the floor ♪
♪ Been on both sides of that door ♪
♪ When love ain't love no more ♪
♪ When it ain't like before,
but there ain't no because ♪
♪ When love ain't love no more ♪
♪ It just is what it is,
when it ain't what it was ♪
(audience cheering)
- One more time, everybody,
let's hear it for Charles Esten.
His new album, "Love Ain't
Pretty" is now available
wherever you get your music.